good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the public
welcome to this meeting of governance
and audit committee
um firstly some housekeeping i do a
project this is my first run out so if i
get anything wrong
please please do feel to give me some
notes for improvement next time
fire evacuation procedure if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices by the stairs either through the
security door behind me
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts
please assemble in holy square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber
filming does anyone intend to film the
meeting
if yes say
brilliant i can skip the rest of it um
restrictions on use mobile phones with
everyone present please ensure their
mobile phone
phones are turned silent and that they
are not used to make or receive phone
calls in the chamber whilst this meeting
is in progress
meeting recording please note this
meeting is being live stream for members
of the public the meeting will also be
recorded and will subsequently be
broadcast on the internet
rule 20.1 would any member who wishes to
speak under council procedure rule 20.1
please announce it now
agenda item 1 apologies for absence i
have received apologies from councillor
ghana are there any other apologies for
absence
okay brilliant thank you that's
councillor shrub
thank you and declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
[Music]
great um gender item three minutes of
the meeting held on 3rd
march 2021 to approve the minutes of the
meeting held on 3rd march 2021 copy
attached
copy attached to the gender pack please
can i have a proposer and a seconder
proposal from councillor pew
and councillor dexter seconded
unless i hear any objections i will take
these as approved
cool um annual internal
audit report gender item four um
i wish to invite christine parker from
east can audit partnership to introduce
the report
thank you chair good evening members
um if i take you to page 12 of the
report
paragraph 1.1 there of the covering
report
sets out the purpose um it is important
for us to confirm our independence
our performance against the metrics and
our compliance with
professional standards and these
assurances
are provided to the committee and it's
most important to feed in your
and and into your annual governance
assurance processes
the report itself is in two parts
the first part if i can move you to
paragraph three page 16 of the report
uh details um the east county audit
partnership against
our performance indicators
and these of course are summarized in
the balance scorecard on appendix 5 at
page 33.
so whilst these are important and it's
reporting back to you
on our commitments that we set out at
the beginning of the year against the
audit plan
the real crux of the report is
from paragraphs for onwards which is
really
the outcomes from the work that we've
undertaken
the other important point to note
members is this is really a summary of
the four previous meetings that we've
held there's nothing new in this report
it's just presenting that information
back to you in a slightly different way
for example in paragraph 4.1 the
recommendations that we've agreed in the
individual pieces of work
are shown split across the criticalities
of critical high medium and low priority
within those audits and paragraph 4.4
shows the different assurances that have
been given at the time of doing those
pieces of work
and in 4.3 we say this repeatedly to the
committee
we go in we do an audit that is a
snapshot in time that's what we see
at the time of doing the audit on the
day and we usually end up with an agreed
action plan as we walk away
and then three or six months later we'll
go back and we'll report back to the
committee on what's changed
as a result of those actions being
implemented and this is very much the so
what
so the progress report set out in 4.3
tell that story
in 4.4 we provide our fraud risk
assurances
before concluding our overall opinion
and from section 5 onwards
i think it's useful just to take stock
and reflect on last year
i know you've heard it many many times
but it was an unprecedented year
and we had quite a lot of advice from
sit for early early days to suggest how
we might
form an opinion in this year it was
perceived
certainly in quarter one when most of
the teams were redeployed
and staff were sent to work in community
hubs and doing other roles
we weren't auditing but within east kent
audit partnership we were very
lucky we're very supported to be able to
get back to the day job
and we really only lost april may and
june and quarter one
so we've reset our targets against 75
percent
as an expected completion because we
lost 25
the advice of course um from zipfer was
how we might limit our scope
and how um we could uh perform enough
work to be able to give you assurances
and to be able to give you an opinion
so i'm very pleased to be at this
position and certainly colleagues and
other benchmarking
audit teams have not got to this
position they've been redeployed on
fraud work throughout the whole period
etc so we're pleased to bring this to
you
the other thing that i'd like to draw
attention to is this year to reflect
changes in auditing standards i've taken
the opportunity to split out the opinion
to cover the three distinct areas of
corporate governance risk management
internal control
and you'll see later in the year when
you receive annual reports from external
audit that was
aligned in with that intention and we've
done that at each of
the internal audit sites that we cover
so just taking a look at that opinion
i think it's useful to just take each
point in turn
the governance arrangements we had
planned to do two pieces of work
of course there are a raft of governance
areas we might look at whistleblower we
might look at codes of conduct
we won't look at everything every year
but we are required to look at aspects
of governance
in the year unfortunately the two pieces
of work that were planned were both
hampered but for different reasons
um and this report is up to the 31st of
march only
informed members since the 31st march
progress has been made and
in included in your quarterly update
would report on the next item on the
agenda
the results of the local code of
corporate governance review
and also the gdpr review is back on
track you have recruited a new
officer and we are discussing a start
date for that one so those pieces of
work will be followed up and brought to
the committee in future
but whilst this work was delayed i'm not
able to provide any further assurances
in this area as we haven't undertaken
any
work in that area moving to 5.2 i
thought it was very useful members to
include at the top of
page 23 the three lines of defense model
and just as a helpful ed memoir
in terms of what how this all fits
together really
so at the first line defense we have the
management controls those things built
in
every day to prevent something to detect
something or to correct something
happening at the very front line
up by that you'll have your second line
of defense and this might be a monthly
reconciliation
or a performance report or risk
management or some other process working
outside of those daily controls
that will help also pick things up put
them back on track
and these are the things that you rely
on your third line defense is us and
this work that we undertake as your
fresh eyes
looking at things to identify risk and
hopefully mitigate those
those areas where fraud and error can
occur
wrapped around this of course you've got
your external audit function
and your regulator regulatory functions
and that could be the food standards
agency the housing regulator other
regulators
so the work goes up course through
senior management and
right at the top of the overarching body
your audit committee
so i thought it was useful to include in
terms of what we're trying to achieve
with our internal control systems
so linking back to what i've just said
about the work that we have been able to
undertake i think you'll see that
some audits were deferred we clearly
couldn't go to the depot and undertake
work where we were restricted to be
at home and we weren't able to travel so
we've actually
really undertaken the work we could
undertake rather than perhaps your
highest profile
risks but those risks will feature in
future audit plans and get back
um into the the overall strategic plan
in accordance with risk and moving
finally to the last paragraph your risk
management arrangements
we have reviewed this before in 2018
it's back in the plan and
we will see we see the output from the
risk management process at this
meeting quarterly so we are confident
that the arrangements are currently
effective but we will be doing an
independent review at some time
bringing that back to you members the
report is for noting but i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you
thank you christine members do you have
any comments or questions
sorry tim what have i forgotten
thank you chair and nothing at all i
just wanted to supplement something that
christine said
um just to illuminate for for members
um in paragraph four it just makes the
point that
there was an incomplete audio plan in
2021
um but that um christine as i
am comfortable that there's been
sufficient coverage during the year
to to prove to enable a proof an opinion
to be provided
um i just also add my thanks to
um the eastern audi partnership team not
only
if they carried out their work
diligently and professionally as they
always do
but they helped us and it seems a long
time ago now
when we were administering um grants
business grants
in the first quarter of 2021 and simon
and simon and christine's colleagues zoe
fennell both volunteered to help the
team of
thanet to ensure a successful rollout of
the business grant scheme and i wanted
to register my thanks to them for that
definitely i think as members we agree
that we'd like to note that thanks
um so the recommendation is
first of all is there any other comments
or questions
great uh recommendation is that the
report is received by members please can
have a proposer and a seconder
proposed by councillor view and second
by councillor dexter
unless i hear any objection i will take
this as approved
approved moving on to agenda item 5 the
quarterly internal audit
update report i would like to ask mr
webb from east kent audit partnership to
introduce the report
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular quarterly internal
audit update report
it provides a summary of the work
undertaken by the east kent audit
partnership
on your behalf since the last committee
meeting in march
and also the performance of the east
kent audit partnership up to the 30th of
june
if i could draw your attention to the
table on page 39 of the agenda pack
that summarises the eight new audit
assignments completed during this period
we were pleased to conclude substantial
assurance in three areas
coastal management land charges and
escape services key performance
indicators
we could concluded reasonable assurance
in a fourth area which was east game
services icct disaster recovery
in two areas we concluded limited
assurance the first was local code of
corporate governance and the reasons
given rise to that limited assurance
are detailed in the bullets on page 47.
we also concluded limited assurance in
the area of public health burials
and the reasons for that assurance are
detailed in the bullets on page 50 of
the agenda pack
however with public health burials we
were under able to undertake the
follow-up
review in the same quarter and as a
result of action taken by management i'm
pleased to report that the assurance
level has risen
to reasonable two further reviews
undertaken during the period
were an hra stock reconciliation to
assist the authority in that area
following the housing stock being
brought back in house from east kent
housing on the 1st of october last year
and also we undertake quarterly benefit
testing of
samples of housing benefit claims
so we undertook 2021 quarters three and
four testing
during the period under review we don't
give assurance
levels for those types of review because
they're not felt to be appropriate
because they're not system reviews
an important part of internal audit work
is follow-up
christine mentions that typically we go
back three to six months
after an original audit is completed
to ascertain whether the agreed action
plan has been implemented
if i could draw your attention to the
table on page 52
that details the 14 follow-ups
undertaken during this period
um a very busy quarter for follow-ups we
don't normally do quite that many
um pleased to report substantial
reasonable assurance in the vast
majority of those
areas after follow-up the table shows
you the original assurance
level the revised assurance level after
follow-up
the original number of recommendations
and the number of recommendations
not yet implemented has at the time of
follow-up
there were three areas that remained
either limited or partially limited
after follow-up
they were street cleaning grounds
maintenance and building control
and the reasons for that are detailed on
pages 53
and 54 and there are management
responses
in those sections we also include
within the pack details of
the individual recommendations which are
outstanding after follow-up and they are
included in the appendices
on page 61 onwards
i've talked about assurance levels
members
undoubtedly have read appendix 2 on page
60
which details the definitions of what
no assurance limited assurance
reasonable assurance or substantial
assurance actually mean
the definitions we use are the sit for
approved definitions
we also detail the definitions of our
recommendation priorities so if we don't
currently have definitions for
recommendations
but we have recommend so we have
benchmarked those against our peers
within kent so
we define recommendations as critical
high medium or low
the previous appendices which is
on page 57 onwards details the
uh 2122 internal audit plan
and performance against it to the 30th
of june 21.
uh we did completed 18.84 as that
thirtieth of june so slightly behind the
twenty-five percent first quarter target
uh but reasonably confident we will make
that up over the following three
quarters
final appendix to draw your attention to
um and you will have seen the version to
the 31st of march within christine's
annual
internal audit reports and that is the
balanced scorecard of performance
indicators
for the year's candidate partnership and
that is detailed
at the end of this agenda item um
and um probably the most important
performance indicator on there is the
plan completion
which as i mentioned is 18.78 at the end
of
uh the first quarter that concludes my
presentation chair but obviously happy
to take questions
that members may have thank you
thank you members are there any
questions or comments
okay uh yeah
uh thank you uh chairman um i'd just
like to ask a question
from simon if
you can just clarify if you have a
planned audit in the future for your
leisure
thank you councillor uh we don't have it
included in the 2122 plan
but it will be certainly considered for
22 23
on going onwards i think with um the
entertainment industry probably one of
the hardest hits during the covet
pandemic
probably it would be fair to allow
colleagues within your leisure
to start to get embedded in doing their
day job
before we undertake an audit in that
area
we could if members were interested
undertake a second follow-up
to the audit of the last cycle
but i think probably it would be too
much to do a full
audit in this current financial year
uh yes council
duckworth uh yeah on
page 62
it's to do with street cleansing um i
wasn't quite sure
that the cabinet approval was for street
cleansing
um one of the bullet points
is to do with zoning arrangements
i don't really know what they are so
oh yeah yeah basically parts of the
district are set into zones so
zone one will be town centres so they
get a higher priority
and as we move out out into the the
villages obviously those change
and that just reflects the amount of
resources and time and
times the bins are empty etc so that's
just a reflection on how we use the
resources in
areas it's so
quite useful when if we get any further
reports if
that was if we could have like a chart
saying what those priorities were
thanks
any other questions comments
and could i ask a question or just be
expanded upon
and with regards to the street cleansing
um
there's a note and i'm not sure which
page it is um that says that the
management said disagreed with the
level of
from crystal to high could you expand a
bit more
as to why that's different to what the
audience's opinion is
yeah the comment from the the uh service
director was
it was put down as a critical but it
wasn't that issue is is about
performance indicators
so what he felt it wasn't actually
critical to the service delivery
on the ground but we are reviewing the
service and we'll be looking at
benchmarking and putting indicators in
place to measure performance
more effectively
[Music]
thank you any other comments
and the recommendation is that the
report is no
is received by members and
police can have a proposer and a
secondar
proposed council pew and secreted by
councillor cup
unless i hear any objection i will take
this as approved
brilliant moving on to a gender item
six annual governance statement and i
would like to welcome
estelle culligan director of law and
democracy who will introduce this report
thanks very much chair good evening
members
so just a brief introduction to the
document before you which is the draft
annual governance statement
for 20 20 2021 it's
produced as required under the accounts
and audit regulations 2015
which state that at least once a year
the council must produce an annual
governance statement
this document is a fairly early draft
it's not for approval tonight
but it's to enable you to have a look at
it have a view
make any comments that you may have and
approve for it to go forward to be
considered by various other
officers over the summer and also by
grant thornton
uh and to be there then completed and
signed off hopefully in the early autumn
hopefully in september but there may be
a bit of slippage on that but
that's what that's what i'm aiming for
the report is self-explanatory
i've tried to organize it in a fairly
user-friendly way
um giving links to the various annual
reports of the relevant committees like
standards and
overview and scrutiny which were brought
forward in march
there's also an outline in there of the
various uh
issues over the year that we've had with
a bit of a summary
from the various teams i'm not going to
go through all that you can
read it no doubt and i just wanted to
address this issue of the action plan
because i know there's been
a few comments on that so every year in
the
annual governance statement there's an
action plan that says the areas that
we're going to look at
throughout the coming year and i have
put an action plan
in there last year's action plan
unfortunately what normally happens is
there is an action plan and then
we report on progress against the action
plan to this committee
either quarterly or you know whenever
whenever there is a
a decent update to give unfortunately
that didn't happen
from last year's annual governance
statement to now
the reason being that document wasn't
published i don't think until the end of
november early december
and then unfortunately due to
circumstances and tim's absence
i've just not had the resources to bring
forward those reviews on a regular basis
but i fully intend that uh sorry what i
was going to say is just because i
haven't reviewed
doesn't mean that things haven't been
going on uh and
the current plan that i've put in the
document
basically shows where we are and
actually in itself it gives a bit of an
update from some of the things that were
in the plan
in the um action plan last year and i
fully intend going forward to bring
regular reviews
to this committee so that you know
exactly where we are
um yes once his statement has been
finalized and published then i would do
that and
bring reviews forward and then just
finally to say that given where we are
with the review intergovernance being
carried out by grant thornton who are
here this evening
the final annual governance statement is
likely to be amended
and we'll take into account the results
of that review
and thank you very much and i'm happy to
take any questions and comments
do members have any comments counselor
pew
thank you chair um estelle there's a
question i have just relating to
uh i believe it's on page 86 disbanding
of east kent hr
so it mentions that we're on track to
bring the service in-house from the
first of september
but what are the risks that are
associated with us missing that target
particularly with i imagine
there's instances of of staff either are
they being brought over
from hr and they're being brought in
houses employees
or are they being say moved on and we're
bringing in new people
and so my question is what is the risk
of us that if we miss that deadline
what's the then next opportunity that we
can then bring it back in-house
thanks very much councillor pugh we are
on target i'm very pleased to report
um the hr team themselves the senior
members of the team have done some
fabulous work
putting together a project plan and
getting everything sorted
the main issue that we had to deal with
was sorting out the staff
and where they're going to go across the
three councils we've managed that
basically through dealing with their
i think we've managed to slot everybody
into either first
or second preference we ask them to put
down three preferences obviously
and more or less everybody was got their
first or the second well everybody got
their first or second preference
and i think most everybody got their
first preference that's what i'm gonna
say
so that is all sorted there we have a
team that is coming over
uh on the first of september that's the
date that we are aiming for
and and it's um
sorry we've been doing the last few
things in terms of consultation we have
to do a consultation
on um measures so they're going to be
brought over that their existing terms
and conditions will continue so they'll
be
not stupid they'll be treated as if
cheapy applies so they will continue
on their dover terms and conditions but
they will be brought into
uh senate district council obviously
going forward if there are any vacancies
vacancies would be out and we do have
one vacancy in the team that i know of
simply because somebody is going
somewhere else and
you know during this period they've
resigned and that post will be
advertised on tanet's terms and
conditions so obviously
as vacancies arrive arise it will be
advertised on our terms and conditions
but as part of that process we're just
in the last stages of doing a bit of
consultation on what are called measures
which are basically the hygiene factors
that will have to change like when they
get paid the date they get paid
um there's one or two other very minor
things that actually have not caused any
issue we're just in those final stages
i'm on leave next week our new hr
manager is on leave this week
she comes back when we're back we're
having a meeting on the um
9th of august and after that we'll be
doing some comms and introducing the
team
and you know giving a little bio of them
all and saying what they'll be doing and
so all on track and then there's some
peripheral stuff which is sort of a
mending of contracts to do with
provision of the hr stuff that you do
like occupational health and all that
sort of thing
that's all in that's all in process
we're doing a data sharing
agreement to cover off anything else
that remains that we might have to share
data between the three councils
um we're amending the shared services
collaboration agreement
dover leading on that i'll have input
into that to
make clear that the hr service is now
removed from that that will be resolved
and
yeah we're on track very exciting
thank you
any other comments from members
okay um estelle one comment from me um
would it be possible to have the table
from the previous year's
annual government statement inputted as
opposed to a link to be able to have a
direct
comparison and in addition to that would
we be able to have
a time frame where we've got actions of
this is what we're going to do when are
we going to do it and then ideally the
responsible post
for it in terms of making it clearer and
more transparent i think that would help
perhaps the committee to keep on task
mid-year when we're looking at what's
being done
yeah i'm happy to do that no problem
brilliant thank you um please another
proposal and a second
to agree the draft and your government
statement
proposal council plea and seconded
by councillor cut i do apologize
counselor pew
um unless i hear any objection i will
take that as approved
cool approved uh moving on to a gender
item seven
annual treasury management review
2020-2021
invite chris blundell to introduce the
review
thank you chair good evening members
i'll um try and keep this as
as brief as possible i appreciate it's a
full agenda and
a fairly dry subject so this is a report
that summarizes a backward look
on our treasury management activities
for the last financial year
um the figures are still provisional at
this stage because they are um
still subject to awarded by grant
thornton colleagues and that will be
undertaken over the next
few months and so the figures are
subject to some change until the audit
is completed
overall i'm pleased to report that all
our activities are operated
within the limits that were agreed
previously by members when we set the
strategy at the start of the
2020-21 year but this key messages that
i'd like to summarize from the report
today
under section three where we look at
capital expenditure
on page 93 of your report pack you'll
see our capital expenditure for the year
was significantly under budget we spent
about
half of what we expected at the start of
the year um
the reasons for that will be detailed in
the outcome report that will be going to
cabinet tomorrow night so members will
be able to
review the details behind that overspent
underspender i apologize
the following section on section four
this covers off borrowing
i'm pleased to say that we can comply
with the potential indicator
to ensure that the amount that we borrow
from banks and financial institutions
was less than the amount that we needed
to fund our capital program that's
called the
capital financing requirements an
important indicator because we're not
allowed to borrow more than we need
and because effective that mean we're
borrowing for revenue purposes and
that's not allowed on the statute so
you'll see on page 93 that the year end
our borrowing position
was 24 million it's well below our
borrowing need
the 56 million that means we've under
borrowed by 32 million pound another way
of thinking of that is that we've used
our own
cash instead of borrowing from banks to
finance our capital expenditure
the tables that follow that they they uh
indicate that we still weigh
within both our operational and
authorized limits it's another positive
note
table five sorry section five the tables
under that section
show our overall positions in terms of
debt through the year
so you see there's not much movement
going from 25 million at the start of
the year to
24.4 million so we redeemed
six hundred and thirty thousand pounds
worth of debts repaid that
and didn't undertake any new borrowing
throughout the year
it shows that during the year we had
first it was at the end of the year we
had 31 million pounds worth of
investments
so that's a net 6 million pound surplus
in terms of investments over debt
and the tables that follow on page 95
show how our debts
and investments are compromised in terms
of their makeup
and time to duration
section six um this has got a very nice
attractive graph in it
it illustrates how interest rates
plunged during the year
and a lot of rates actually going
negative at some point during the year
obviously this was as
um institutions responded um and markets
responded to the pandemic
uh this uh the fact that interest rates
went negative this supports our position
where we've under borrowed so instead of
actually
looking to take lots of cash on board
we've used our cash balances instead to
finance the capital
expenditure while interest rates are at
such
low historic lows
section eight if i skip ahead and on
page 101
um just having a little look at our
performance on
uh investments because of the
aforementioned
uh sort of drop in rates you'll see that
we've got an average return of
0.23 and it's not actually too bad
it sounds pretty mightily but it's not
too bad achievement when you consider
that
many institutions are actually charging
charging for us to place money with them
at what you consider a negative rate so
we've got 0.23 on our investments
throughout the year
so the committee are asked to note the
potential indicators
that are in there and also make any
further comment before the report goes
ahead to
council for approval but i'm happy to
take any questions on the content of the
report
thank you chris members any questions
counselor p thank you chair and and
thank you chris
and you mentioned that our borrowing is
substantially lower
um than it potentially could be and you
also reference the um
the boring rates and the bank of england
the bank rates um is it within our
interest to
at this time and into the future if
rates continue to be low
to when we need to borrow
more borrow the money externally rather
than use our own funds
or is that a strategy that isn't as
necessarily
uncomplicated as i seem to think it is
that's a very very good question council
p so it is something that we consider
it's it's a risk that we need to think
about because
at the moment we're using our own
resources but if there's
you can consider an opportune time to
borrow while rates are low and we need
to consider that
um if you look i can't remember exactly
where it is on
the report if i try and find it
it's an interest rate forecast here we
are page 98
um top of page 98 this is a interest
rate forecast that's provided by our
treasury management
consultants and you can see that the
bank rates
they're forecasting to stay at 0.1
percent
all the way through to march 24 so we
use those forecasts and form
the strategy that we take as one the
best time is to invest
at the moment we still think it's best
to continue this this position of using
our cash balances
but that is a position that we
continually monitor
tim myself and treasury management
colleagues and advisors will look at
that
to make sure that we're striking at the
right moment to make the most of the
council's
borrowing opportunities
uh tim thanks chair
thanks for that chris i just wanted to
add that um
we we have net investments so if we've
if we've got money to spare
then we invest it and we invest next to
no interest
and we we are next to no interest on it
so it's not even worth investing
so if we've got that cash and we've got
a capital program we may as well use
that money to fund the capital programme
i um i understand the underlying
point of the question from council pew
which is if interest rates are low why
don't we borrow now
and obviously now's a good time to
borrow rather than when interest rates
are 5 10
but of course when you do borrow you're
committed to a long-term repayment
period
25 sometimes 50 years and that hits the
revenue account and that hits the
council tax and that will hit services
so our strategy has been prudent for
ever since i've been
here a prudent one to look at internal
borrowing where we can do it
and to minimize the need to borrow
unless there's a guaranteed income
stream or cost saving on a capital
project that'll be our general principle
and of course we wouldn't borrow to
invest speculatively we're not allowed
to do that
thank you councillor towning
and we actually use some of our reserves
to actually get a balanced
budget are we looking to replace some of
this
funding that we've taken from our
reserves
by actually using our internal funds to
move across
and by doing so then you know you could
also borrow from a
outside to give you a much better
opportunity to build back
your reserves
um the difference is obviously there's a
differential the amount that we can
borrow at
is more expensive than the amount that
we can invest at so if we were to borrow
money from
a bank typically we'll be paying north
of two percent well
we've seen as i've explained that we'll
only be getting around 0.2 percent
on our investments in general so that
actually a cost to us
at the moment in time to taking that
borrowing on board which is the reason
that we would take the strategy of using
our our own cash
balances to fund capital expenditure
rather than looking to take
on additional cash by borrowing from
external financial institutions
thank you any other comments or
questions
great um please have a proposal and a
second
to recommend this report to full council
for approval
proposed by councilman pugh and seconded
by councillor cup
uh unless i hear any objection i will
take this recommendation as approved
approved um moving on to agenda item
eight
corporate risk management quarterly
updates on our caller
again back to mr blundell to introduce
the review of corporate risks
thank you chair so members will be aware
that governance and audit is the
committee
charged with overseeing the council's
approach to risk management and as such
the committee is asked to
approve this review of our corporate
risks
under the table shown in section 4
you'll see a summary of our highest
scoring corporate risks
and then beyond that table if i can turn
your attention
attention to section 6 on page 118
you'll see there's a new risk that's
been added related to governance
as detailed in the report and then
beyond that on the following page you'll
see that homelessness
risk rating has increased and as such
this risk has been highlighted again on
the corporate risk register and brought
back to the committee's attention
i'm happy to take any questions
do members have any questions
okay and one recommendation
chris is could we have the next
level down of risks identified in these
reports rather than
we're seeing everything rag rated red
perhaps it might be an ideal to have the
ones that are
the i don't know the reddest amber so
that we've got an overview and then we
can start tackling an issue before
it gets to that that red zone i think
perhaps members if you agree
wonderful and yeah absolutely not a
problem thank you
brilliant any other comments questions
no great
um please can have a proposal and a
second off
to approve it um proposed by council pew
and secreted by councillor cup um unless
i hear any objection i will take this as
approved
approved agenda item nine governance and
audit subgroup and accounts updates i'm
going back to chris blundell
to present this item thank you chair um
you won't have to bear with me for too
much longer i apologize the series the
reports were coming from me one day but
here we go
okay so excuse me this report is asking
the committee to
approve the establishment of a sub-group
to undertake a detailed review of the
statements of accounts so
the committee is charged with approving
the accounts every year and the accounts
are highly complex and obviously they
are presented to
the committee often with only seven
working days
uh time to consider them so the purpose
of
setting up subgroups allows the
committee sufficient time to review the
draft accounts
in detail which will hopefully give the
committee sufficient comfort assurance
to approve them when they're presented
it's proposed that there are four named
members on the sub-group but
more from the committee can attend and
participate if they wish to do so
it's also proposed to waive the need for
political balance on the committee
um subgroup and this will require a nem
comm vote
the term of reference of the subgroup
set up
at annex one um in terms of the accounts
themselves
providing an update on that um the
drafts need to be published by saturday
and will well placed to do that
either tomorrow or friday they'll then
be subject to audit by
our colleagues and friends at grant
thornton and then
following that they'll be presented to
the committee for final approval by the
end of september
i'm happy to take any questions
any questions or comments from members
yes please
just for the clarity um a nemcon vote
means that every member of this panel
has to vote in favor
of removing proportionality if anybody
abstains
or votes against it that element falls
um and you would have to then have
proportionality on that panel
okay that's a pew
sorry thank you chair nick so just to
clarify if it then fails
how does it then become how do we then
sort out proportionality on a group of
four when there are four political
groups and
varying sizes we'll go away and work it
out
i i look forward to being put on this
group now as a matter of vengeance thank
you nick
do members have any other comments
brilliant
please have a proposal and a second for
the recommendation of setting up a
governance and audit subgroup
uh proposed by councillor pugh seconded
by councillor
whitehead unless i hear any objections i
will take this as approved
great um moving
as long as no deep stains you just ask
if it
starts coming but then you'll be fine
okay brilliant and
moving on to agenda item 10 the external
audit plan
and i now invite sarah iron manga to
present this report
um thank you chair i'm just going to
pass to my colleague nick halliwell who
is the manager on the audit to take you
through the plan
thank you sarah so our audit plan sets
out the scope of our audit of the
council
for 20 20 21 it looks at both the
financial statement order and the value
for money
audit that we do for the council on
pages nine to ten of the pack it sets
out the significant risks for the audit
and these risks are in line with the
significant risks of the prior year
audit
and they focus around the valuation of
other land and buildings
council dwellings and investment
property
the pension liability that the council
has and also
the risk of management override of
control and the risk of management
override of control
we use data analytics to select journals
that are unusual
and then we do test we then test these
for the risk of management bias
on pages on the board pages 11 to 12
it sets out the new standards that have
been put in place regarding accounting
estimates
this is after a change to iso 540
with the changes to the accounting
estimates there is a greater focus on
our audit regarding the disclosures
around accounting estimates this year
and we are doing additional work
regarding this with management
um at the committee that you've just set
up
we are expecting uh management to take
our additional questions regarding
estimates and present those to those
charged with governance
and because the the additional
procedures that we're required to
undertake regarding this is also to
ensure that though both those charts of
governance and management fully
understand the estimates that
are in place at the council within the
financial statements
on slide 14 we set out what our
materiality for the audit is
this is our planning materiality and
this may change when we receive the
final
accounts and this sets the materiality
at 2.6 million
we are also required to report to the
committee
any errors or issues that we identify
that are above 113
000 which is the triviality limit that
we have set
on page 17 of the pack it then sets out
the sort of time frames of the audit
we will under take the audit at the end
of august and then we will look to
complete the audit by the end of
september
however i would like to bring to your
attention the increased pressures that
kova 19 has placed
on audits since the pandemic has taken
place
with us undertaking them remotely and
this takes longer
and there is also coupled with that the
increased pressures that the increased
regulatory environment that we are
working under
and this we're still hoping to achieve
the end of september deadline
but i just wanted to raise the point
regarding that
then on pages 15 to 16 it sets out the
new standards regarding the value for
money work that we
undertake and there are new requirements
set out following the redmond review
regarding this work
and these these these new requirements
require us to report both
on the financial statement risks um
the way that the the way that uh the
council
has the governance of the council and
the free ease which is economy
efficiency
effectiveness of the council um this
increased
work that is required on the value for
money work will mean that
this opinion will come later than the
audit opinion
and will come hopefully in order in
autumn
um finally i'd just like to report on
the work that we've undertaken on grants
work
um we have now finished the housing
benefit grant's work and the port
housing receipts grant work and
have signed this opinion both opinions
and then i'd like now to ask if there
are any questions
members do you have any questions or
comments
um would members please note the report
okay moving on to agenda item 11
exclusion of the public impress i'd like
to introduce
estelle culligan
thanks very much chair um thank you
members before you go on to debate this
item in the next item
i just want to i just want to reiterate
the advice
i've given you in my role as acting
monitoring officer which i
emailed around to you all earlier today
and hopefully you've all got it and
you've all managed to read it
i don't intend to go through that report
that advice in detail now because it's
very clear
i would urge you my advice sorry follows
that advice of sarah iron manga who i'm
going to
refer to in a minute to say a few words
and i would urge you to follow that
advice
uh about whether to take item 12
in a private uh in confidential session
uh for all the reasons i've set out in
my advice and also sarah has
um emailed as well so that's just what i
wanted to say about that members thank
you very much
thank you um i just uh i wanted to add
three i've got three things i want to
say about
this uh this vote it's clearly your
decision
as members to do this um but the first
three things are the things i want to
say the first is
these are emerging findings we cannot
complete our work
until the council's disciplinary
process has completed so it is unusual
for us to be reporting
um partly completed work so our findings
may change
so that's a really important point and
the second point
is and i set this out in an email to
group leaders recently
um my concern is that there is a
discussion
either on my report or conversations
that happen
in today's meeting that could be deemed
to prejudice
that that disciplinary committee this is
running and those processes
so in making that decision i would
expect you
as a group of members to to really
assess that risk before you make that
decision and then thirdly as your
external auditor i do expect you to
listen to the advice of your monitoring
officer that is why you have a
monitoring officer
it is your choice if you choose to go
against her advice then you need to be
able to articulate
that reason very clearly
and those were just the three things i
wanted you to think about as you go into
making this
choice
thank you sarah and estelle um
the recommendation is that the public
can press be excluded from the meeting
for agenda item 12 as it contains exempt
information as defined in paragraph 1
and 3 of part one and schedule 12a
of the local government at 1972 as
amended
police can have a proposer and a second
up to exclude the present public from
the remaining agenda item
proposed by councillor dexter and
seconded by councillor
duckworth um unless i hear any objection
i will take this as
approved oh
sorry um
council p sorry thank you chair i just
wanted to uh propose that we decide to
not exclude the press in public
from the meeting um i can give my
reasons now
if this is the time for debate or i can
wait
thank you councillor pugh sorry just a
bit of advice because we have a proposal
seconded by a councillor dexter to
exclude the
present public the best way to do it is
to take a vote on that if that fails
then we can go to councillor pew for his
proposal
is that okay thank you
and those in favor of excluding the
prison public from the remaining agenda
item
please raise your hand
um
those against please raise your hand
three and any abstentions
okay um so that proposal is carried to
exclude
um the press and the public